for example let's go take a look at the
front page of our conference application
first let's look at it in landscape mode
on a tablet now let's look at it on a
phone see how the layout is different
let's take a look at this on the desktop
and see how it adjusts when you drag the
window you can see how the buttons pop
into two rows when the window gets too
narrow to fit all four comfortably let's
take a look at the magic that makes this
happen it's actually quite simple the
menu items are laid out inside of flex
box and the items inside that flexbox by
default are told to take up forty six
percent of the available space that
means of course that only two items will
fit on a line however there's an at
media rule that overrides this if
there's a minimum width of the window of
500 pixels in that case the items will
each only take up twenty-four percent of
the space so all four items will fit on
a single line using flexbox can be a
great way to transform your page you can
change flex direction or flex order to
make dramatic interface changes like the
one I did in the audio recorder earlier
on